Wesley is in Amarillo hi Wesley how are
you I'm good how are you better than I
deserve how can I help I am a student in
massage Moore's business class and we
are studying your curriculum and we just
wanted to know how can you stay out of
debt with all of the living expenses and
your college expenses well number one
year number one cost that you can adjust
when you're picking out school to stay
that free is you pick out a less
expensive school school choice is your
most important element in going
debt-free college and if you've looked
at schools Wesley you know they vary
dramatically from one school to another
I mean the cost changes is just dramatic
the second thing you do is you're in
high school now and so you start work
now and you plan to work through school
I worked 40 to 60 hours a week and
carried a full load and graduated in
four years and when you work that much
and I'm not talking about flopping
whoppers for minimum wage I'm talking
about you know starting a business or
cutting grass or babysitting and
nannying or making websites I don't care
what you do but get something where you
can make some money obviously and then
work your tail off while you're in
school and you're able to pay cash that
way as well the third thing is go to my
scholly comm and start working on
scholarships now and you need to spend
30 minutes to an hour every day applying
for scholarships and apply for the
little ones
a lot of people don't apply for the
little 250 500 dollar ones they think
they have to get ten thousand dollar
ones and so everybody applies for the
ten thousand and nobody applies for the
250 but go get you you know go get 10 15
20 of those 250s and all of a sudden you
get school paid for if you watch what
you're doing and her five hundreds or
thousands or whatever I mean 10 10 1000
so so the combination of those things
school choice is the most important one
number one number two work number three
applying for scholarships and working
your tail end off at that treating
treating applying for scholarships like
it's a job and just doing that and we
have lots of students all over America
going to school completely debt free and
that's tuition and cost of schooling and
every I mean cost of living and
everything of course if you take your
first two years at home living at home
and knock out a lot of your core
curriculum stuff at the local community
college your costs go way down on your
living expenses because you're at home
still and of course community college
costs almost nothing and in some states
it does cost nothing some states it's
free so on and then transfer just make
sure what you're studying and where
you're studying is transferable to a
four-year school and you can knock one
or two years out that way as well that's
another way to keep your cost down but
the big thing is just be very very aware
of what it costs and be looking at the
you know what this tuition here is I
mean what's the University of Texas
versus SMU and you look at the
difference in those two you'll be blown
away at you know one is eight times more
or whatever it is you know these private
schools are very very expensive and so
again nothing wrong with going to an
expensive private school you just have
to have the money and you're asking me
how to go debt-free which means that you
know most people that we're answering
this for don't have the money and so you
want to avoid the debt by keeping your
costs down your income up and adding as
many scholarships as I can possibly add
in the process good question sir
appreciate you calling in hold on I'm
going to give you a copy of Anthony
O'Neill's book national best-selling
book that he wrote with Rachael Cruz
graduate Survival Guide five mistakes
you can't afford to make in college and
student loan that's one of them I think
you got to get away from Wesley and all
of you listening to it Wesley's question
is you have to get away from this idea
that there's only one way to do things
and that's it there's no way to get a
car to shove a car payment know what a
best student loan
without me what no way to be a student
without a student loan
there's no way to travel without a
credit card and once you just remove the
idea that that's even something I'm
willing to do okay given that I don't
borrow money now how am I going to do it
given that I don't borrow money how am I
going to travel given that I don't
borrow money how am I going by car given
that I don't borrow money how am I going
to school and then you start thinking
differently about it but if you just
surrender and you want to be normal and
act like everybody else
well you can do that if you want but
normal sucks you don't want to be normal
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]